Carlos asks curious how you feel about
the impact you've made on people you've
touched and inspired over the years
Carlos thank you so much for that
question it's very sweet pie you know a
lot of you really know me because you've
been following my career for quite a
while and we interact quite a bit and I
think I'm more tangibly untouchable than
a lot of the other kind of people that
look like me and we engage quite a bit
and I have a lot of context back to
question number one in comparison to
others and all that blah blah blah but
the truth is most of them really really
really know me and I think that you know
with the with the hustler and
businessman and they and the North Star
of buying the New York Jets one would
say he loves and wants to buy the Jets
more than anything and thus the money
associated with that process is very
important to him it is a distant second
to know that I've been gifted with a
communication style that touches people
that makes them you know maybe I'm
saying the same thing they've heard
before it's either my conviction or it
comes to my soul in such a way I talk
about what I believe in so much that
it's been able to move people crush it
was clearly a catalyst because that book
really did move people's careers so many
of you have been affected it blows my
mind actually to think about how many
people have been affected even in small
ways creating more positivity for some
people there's just so many variables of
how I've affected people and I don't say
that in like look at how cool I am I'm
just so goddamn thankful you know it's
you know so how do I think about it I
think it is my legacy I think it is the
essence of Who I am as a human being and
it is the singular thing that I'm most
proud of and it gives me enormous
confidence of what kind of parent I'm
going to be and that makes me very very
happy